[Applause]
kelsey you are performing with dolly
parton tonight
to be around people like her as a newer
female artist you're just like
okay that's how it's done i'm taking
notes i'm in the school of dolly parts
professor parton was back as an acm host
the first time since 2000 oh and that's
the same year her co-host gabby barrett
was born i met her last night she was
like oh it's you when i stood next to
her to kind of practice and rehearse
gave her a hug i'm like am i hugging her
too tight am i not hugging her tight
enough fellow idol alum kelly clarkson
delivered this show-stopping dolly
tribute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i was backstage trying not to cry my
false eyelashes off and
i'm slinging snot every direction and
tears
i know that
whitney is smiling down on us tonight
another big moment
carrie underwood's vegas style aerial
entrance
when somebody said how would she feel
about descending from
the ceiling i was like i feel good about
that jason aldean and carrion
gary and jason took home single of the
year but backstage carrie was feeling
the love for miranda lambert after 17
years miranda finally won entertainer of
the year but she wasn't there instead
she accepted virtually from london where
she's headlining a show i've been
waiting for this for a really really
long time
i actually never thought it would happen
miranda's long overdue
for winning this award so i couldn't be
more proud of her as a sister in this
genre of music
[Music]
miranda and l king also won video of the
year beating taylor swift's i bet you
think about me which was directed by
taylor's bestie blake lively ichi was
exclusively on set with miranda and l as
they shot the 80s inspired party anthem
drunk we both got to jump around and you
know wear glitter and we needed to yeah
and this winner chris stapleton gave a
sweet shout out wayland is 13 today it's
his birthday happy birthday my daughter
birthday mini me weyland and sister
aydah posed on the blue carpet with mom
and dad but thomas rhett arrived without
wife lauren why
our kids are still sick and she couldn't
make it out it's like it's killing her
not to be here
[Music]
last time i saw you
you only had one daughter now you have
two how's it feel it's awesome man she's
uh my wife's a superwoman so she's got
her sleeping through the night kane
brown's wife katelyn was by his side two
months since welcoming second daughter
cody jane and he wasn't the only acm
awards star praising their better halves
lainey's looking beautiful over there
performer and dad of six walker hayes
gave a bear hug to his wife in the
audience co-host slash nominee gabby
barrett made it date night with her
performer hubby kade fainter
it means more than words to have him
with me and it's parents night out how
much do you miss baby bayla right now a
lot i my sister is watching her and i
constantly ask my sister i'm like did
she eat lunch did she eat dinner how is
she doing i'm always asking about her
now god willing do you hope to expand
the family oh absolutely
[Applause]
mom and dad's night out i know it's fun
jason aldean and wife brittany
celebrated his single of the year win
with carrie underwood but can we get a
future collab from the next generation
you know her son jacob is three years
old
navy is three years old could they be
the next country couple i mean i'm not
opposed or is navy never allowed to date
that's that's probably accurate yeah i
don't know if i'm gonna have much say in
that but uh yeah we'll see she's pretty
strong headed you know what i mean also
strong-headed co-host jimmy allen
kissing wife alexis and closing the door
on having more kids oh i'm done i'm done
i retired my jersey how does your wife
feel about that she's okay with it we
went from man-to-man to zone coverage
once we had that third one and uh it's a
big jump people talk about well yeah two
three is not a lot it is
marin morris performed with her
childhood guitar she and hubby ryan
heard co-wrote the song for her new
album which has a nod to sun hayes he's
doing good he's about to be two and he's
got his first pair of cowboy boots this
week
so he's feeling sassy please welcome
kelsey oswalt and luke
this yellowstone husband and wife are
about to welcome baby number two in
season five and you're gonna have a
prosthetic baby bump to look forward to
what are your thoughts going into that
oh my goodness let's go honey i'm ready
for like i'm also ready to have a sweet
little baby on set
another couple hitting the acm carpet
hardy and fiance cali ryan how is
wedding planning going we've had a
couple of setbacks we fired our wedding
planner hardy's songwriter of the year
win was announced before the broadcast
backstage he was clearly still in shock
i
don't think i've fully
processed the whole situation morgan
hardy's best friend morgan wallen won
the coveted album of the year i'd also
like to thank everyone who has shown me
grace along the way it was a polarizing
win just over a year ago morgan was
caught using the n-word he apologized
and was banned from radio and last
year's acm awards me and my fiance cried
i think more
over that award than than this one
everybody
deserves a second chance hey next girl
miss carly pierce you are double fisting
here in vegas good it's good i'm into it
carly pierce carly won female artist of
the year and performed the ashley
mcbride duet never wanted to be that
girl which won music event of the year
now you have quite a few trophies at
home so where do these go
they all go on the mantle and if you
come to my house you have to acknowledge
them i don't want you to touch them but
you have to see them and know that
they're there
[Music]
lady wilson lainey wilson took home
three awards including song of the year
holy moly um somebody asked me earlier
they said where you gonna put that thing
i said i'm gonna put it on my mantel
next to my dog pudding
brothers osbourne
duo of the year brothers osborne how
does that feel feels good i don't know
uh we only got one of these right here
so i don't know who's taking it at home
no sibling rivalry when brothers
osbourne closed the show with an
electrifying performance as these boots
are made for walking alongside britney
spencer
old dominion embraced the vegas vibe by
betting ten thousand dollars they would
win their fifth group of the year award
[Music]
you got the trophy right here how does
it feel sick heavy feels like the other
four that we had
[Music]
who you wearing
[Music]
i went like saint laurent head to toe
with some jewels it's like sleeker than
i'm used to and i i kind of love that
it's very fun i feel kind of head burny
kelsey channeled that old hollywood
glamour before going country and shorts
and boots to perform with dolly and then
revealed her abs in a two-piece purple
number ripped from the runway also
rocking three looks carrie underwood
on the carpet her custom dolce gabbana
mini dress embroidered with rose gold
crystals showed off her killer legs then
there was this confetti dress and then a
change into these micro shorts that once
again showed off her stems
it's so much fun to get dressed up we've
never done a blue moment never like pull
off the shoulder so i just i loved it it
was one of the first dresses i tried on
you got the blue eye shadow yeah we
thought it was a blue moment tonight i
feel just like ariel i mean i'm about to
sing part of your world here we go
performer brooke eden gave us all
mermaid vibes while gabby barrett went
bold in black leather pants and a red
dress with big shoulders maren morris
also rocked leather in vintage dior
before getting casual and ripped jeans
to take the stage because when country
music takes over vegas it's all about
the sparkles and feathers fringe denim
leather
suede it's been my thing i love texture
wyoming the rocky mountains and the west
in general bail bottom country baby
leather silver i i don't know with black
trim i just saw the pattern and i liked
it so i said that's that's the one i'm
gonna roll with my zipper uh fell off
right before so i'm taped up
oh you're you're taped over yeah so i'm
like trying to like to stand really
still right now so make sure the
camera's just like right here you know
[Music]